从你内心来看的话，
你没有真正瞧得起你的妻子，
为什么我说你心里没有真正瞧得起这个女人呢？
因为你刚刚用了一个词叫宽恕啊，
你说他如果不这么干的话，
我就能宽恕他，
就从这个措辞就能看出来，
就在你的心里的话，
你一直是把他看成是你的手下，
我宝媳妇从认识到现在为止，
儿子17岁了，
你二三岁，
认识了18年，
大概是9月18号晚上吧，
他眼里攻击我的家里了，
我就吼了他几声，
他9月18号晚上就把车子藏起来了，
我9月19号早上不是要开车去农村嘛，
农村在建别墅，
我早上6点多钟就起来了，
一直跟他打电话，
他不接，
到我家里找他呢，
我就很气愤，
给了他两个耳光，
本来这个事情从我心里来说是他错了，
他哪怕是后面不再把车藏起来，
我都可以宽恕他，
小区的那个保安嘛，
就把他拉住了，
他说你这样做不对，
他说你老公干的是正事，
你应该赶紧去把车开过来，
家里等着用，
他没有开出来，
带到保安去开了，
然后就开到帽子叔叔那里去，
帽子叔叔来了之后呢，
我说我们住在这个辖期，
免得老师麻烦帽子叔叔，
要不我们就签几份协议吧，
他就托我朋友来说和这个事情，
劝我低头，
我不肯低头呢，
然后昨天上午呢，
他就跟帽子叔叔施压嘛，
他说要依法处理我，
帽子叔叔给我说的是，
他说最好是低一下头，
因为我正在那个一批党员。
他说这个行政处罚能问题不大，
但是会影响你入党，
因为我是农村的，
我爸妈都不在了，
家里人呢也都劝我，
他说低一个头，
但是我感觉这一次事件当中呢，
我没有错，
我跟他是有很深的隔阂，
感觉学生家里很穷，
我爸爸就带着我在外面要饭，
爸爸死了之后呢，
我就辍学了，
辍学了去深圳，
经常然后就学徒，
学徒然后在厂里就做那个组长，
我跟他认识，
就是我在厂里做组长的时候，
她在我手下做事，
跟他结婚之后生了我儿子，
我就开始创业，
在所有的创业过程当中吧，
他完全没有配合我，
到2014年我妈妈查出了癌症，
我第二次创业的那个网恋，
我就没有心情打理了，
我就把那个停止了，
我又去跟别人打工了，
我媳妇跟我说，
她说我们两个人赚的钱，
个人赚的钱自己存吧，
但是她在我的那个家人面前，
她说应该要找最好的医生，
用最好的药去医疗，
我觉得她就是一个两面人吧，
我妈是2014年得癌症，
2017年死了，
到2017年为止，
我生活中所有的苦难是我多次扛下来了，
从18年19年我开始第三次创业，
刚好自己就进入了一个比较好的赛道吧，
从19年的那个收入，
年收入20多万嘛，
上升到去年大概是90多万嘛，
家庭财富也在计算了，
就是原来买了一套二手房。
然后现在又买了一套，
两套房子，
加起来大概200万嘛，
买了一台奔驰，
还有一些金条啥的，
第三次创业的过程中，
我觉得他也没有给我什么助理，
我一直在扯后腿，
因为我做的这个东西是一个人住，
我想扩大团队，
我招男孩子进来嘛，
我自己担心的男孩子野心比较大，
会抢我的客户，
所以我就招女孩子进来，
女孩子进来的情况下呢，
他就老是要查我跟我的助手的那个聊天记录，
导致呢就是别人做的时间一两个月就跑了，
然后我就想着吧，
我再浪一步吧，
我就一个人都不招吧，
大不了以后我就带我儿子干这个。
今年年初的时候吵架，
他去了深圳，
他说他要自己出去工作，
到了5月15号回来了呢，
然后当天他回到家的当天，
就搞了我的那个某新的交易流水嘛，
那我里面有那个三笔交易是说不清楚的，
说不清楚是什么情况呢？
第一笔啊，
凌晨一点多钟开了一个那个维也纳，
他说问我为什么凌晨一点多钟去开那个维也纳，
是因为我农村在建那个房子，
那个宅基梯的审批有求于人，
是帮别人开的，
那个维也纳不是我自己住的，
我为什么不能这样直截了当的告诉他呢？
就是因为如果我告诉了他，
他会去跟那个人对峙，
我下不来一台。
第二件事情是我在我们那个公司旁边那个烟酒店里面，
也是用那个某型扫码兑换了1000块钱现金，
然后他说这个1000块钱现金我是拿去计洗掉，
我当时没有想。
起吧，
因为我的工作很忙嘛，
我真的想不起来这1000块钱干嘛，
自己反复的思考可以，
这个1000块钱是交给我们村里的那个老村长，
拿去做公益了，
修那些族谱嘛。
这是第二件事情，
我也不想跟他说，
如果跟他说了的话，
他还是会去对峙。
第三件事情，
有一个246块钱的一个饭店吃饭的记录，
他是246块钱，
他说我一个人肯定吃不完，
去那个饭店里面查那个吃饭的账单，
发现那个246块钱是点了四菜一汤，
他就一直问我跟谁吃的，
我当时也是想目起来，
然后反复的肥，
是请了那个风水先生吃的，
两个人吃的饭，
我感觉我的生活很压抑很压抑，
你们那个房子是登记在谁的名下，
房子就是共同共有，
车子是他名下，
现在你的这个公司有几个员工啊，
我一个人住，
你现在想表达的意思是你没有办法再原谅你的妻子，
是这意思吗？
我感觉心里过不了这个坎吧，
我是该怎么做决策？
嗯，
实话说啊，
第一你确实非常上进，
第二呢，
你自己也是一步一步走过来，
也是非常不容易，
你咱们的出生你能有今天非常不容易，
一儿一女有一个家庭，
有自己的事业，
挺不容易的。
但是你给我讲的这些细节的背后，
我作为女人，
我能看到的是什么呢？
就你老婆还是很在乎你的，
她要不在乎你的话，
她不会管你，
不会说对峙这个，
对峙那个，
在这个婚姻的十几年。
20年的时光当中，
你多多少少一定是干了什么事儿，
就是让他抓到过，
曾经出现过，
在男女关系上，
他才会草木皆兵，
才会这么管，
你可以不说，
但是以我的经验来看的话，
那多多少少一定是出现过，
才会出现今天的这个局面。
再有一个是什么呢？
你打人那个事儿，
你说破天了啊，
他把车藏起来了，
咱可以打车呀，
就他不是偷人了，
他不是把什么要了你的命根子了，
他只是把车藏起来了，
你完全可以打车解决，
那你上来夸夸两耳刮子，
你说破天了也是你不对，
这个关于这个两个耳刮子，
我反佛是思考了，
我觉得也是我不对，
即使是两个人要分开，
也不能带着仇恨这样分开最重要的点是什么呢？
因为某种程度上，
其实我跟你有一些相同类似的这样一个过往吧，
都是从社会的底层，
从阴沟里面爬出来的人，
像我们这种从阴沟里面爬出来的人呢，
很多时候啊，
往往记仇不容易记恩，
为什么说记仇不记恩呢？
我们往往能记住那些瞧不起我的，
打压我的，
在背地里面贬损我的那些人，
但是像你老婆，
在你一无所有的时候，
20年前你啥啥啥也没有啊，
穷小子一个呀，
是吧，
她嫁给了你，
她富身家，
她压到你身上了，
也很难得的，
20年前你真的是什么都没有诶，
她给你生儿子是吧？
你老说她在事业上没有帮衬你，
她全富身家都压给你了，
她给你生了个儿子，
他事业上还怎么？
方言，
他得带孩子，
说我在外面有点什么，
这个我是确实没有，
但是我是这样讲的，
我感觉他应该是带了上一段婚姻的伤害进入了这段婚姻，
他上一段婚姻被人背叛了，
是不是他在我面前说的原话是他家教很严，
父母不允许他谈恋爱，
他说在认识我之前不认识其他任何男孩子，
通过一些细枝末节的事情可以感知出来，
他应该是在认识我之前是生过孩子，
哥们儿，
你们两口子这事儿你说什么细枝末节，
他如果生过一个孩子，
这玩意儿能瞒得住吗？
他家里面亲戚朋友能不知道吗？
你这玩意就纯属栽赃，
纯属臆想，
你如果没有真凭实句，
你上来就说怀疑他以前生过孩子，
你生过孩子这事儿你瞒不住啊，
他跟我不是同一个地方的人，
是外省的，
就算是外省的，
你跟他现在也结婚那么多年了，
你就没去过他的家乡吗？
不认识他的父母兄弟吗？
不认他的同学朋友吗？
邻居吗？
怎没有生过孩子，
孩子在哪？
这个事儿这玩意儿还能包得住，
而且你都结婚20年了，
他都给你生了一儿一女了，
这事儿你没有直接问过，
你在这儿怀疑，
通过他说的原话就是那么说的，
就是说他家教很严，
在认识我之前不认识其他任何人，
那你不能因为说你心里有一个怀疑，
你没有任何证据啊，
大哥，
是没有证据，
这个是事实，
那你这人就跟那个谁是一个路子吧，
他怀疑他儿子不是他亲生的，
他做了个亲子鉴定，
亲子鉴定99.99%，
事实是。
亲子关系，
那他还说那还有0.01%的可能呢，
你就跟那个男的差不多了，
你现在了解自己的死活涂了，
那这么说的话，
我觉得这女的能跟你过20年，
你烧高香吧，
还给你生了一儿一女，
你在这个世上也没有亲人了，
这一对儿女是你亲生的了，
你就好好维系这段关系，
要再跟别的女的过的话，
跟谁也过不好，
因为你性格有问题，
但是这个事情我从来没有提出过，
是你刚才说我可能有什么做了他不放心的事情，
大哥，
我跟你讲啊，
你要跟我辩论的话，
今天我就跟你干上了，
你如果20年有这个疑问你都没有提过的话，
那你性格更可怕，
刚开始认识的时候提过，
为什么提过呢？
我跟你讲就是提过一次，
是他生我儿子的时候，
在那个医院的那个出院记录上，
那个医生写的很清楚，
就是说某某是已婚遗产式，
就是身体的某个部位。
还有一个细节是我跟他结婚的时候，
我说我们个地风俗不同，
我说拿一点钱到你们老家去摆酒，
他说他们老家的风俗是怀了孩子不能摆酒，
他在他们那边是没有摆酒的，
没有任何的那个出嫁的仪式的，
我跟他不是现在交往了这么多年嘛，
他们那里别人怀了孕的，
生了孩子的照样可以摆酒，
但是他在她家是没有摆酒的，
这是第一个细节，
第二个是医疗记录，
第三个是刚开始认识的时候，
就经常医院上医院什么炎症这样的那样的问题，
你把我类比成那个99.9%那个，
那跟他应该是不一样的。
说医院上。
孩子生完孩子了，
还是生孩子之前写的是已婚已产妇，
这事要说明白啊，
就是生孩子之前查体嘛，
不是有一个那个诊疗记录嘛，
不是初产儿的话，
她会生的就很慢嘛，
但是她生过儿子就很快嘛，
那这个不重要吧，
如果说她确实生过孩子跟着我，
我能接受啊，
只是说你刚才无意间说起，
你说我是不是做了什么样的对不起他的事情，
我说我没有，
她的疑心病应该是上一段婚姻带来的，
我是因患脱发，
告诉你这个情况，
那她这些年就没有承认过，
没有承认过之前有孩子，
从来不承认跟之前的孩子没有这一毛钱的关系，
没有经济上的往来，
都很正常。
在农村生了孩子，
然后重新出嫁，
我们这里也有这样的情况，
就是重新出嫁之后，
跟原来的孩子就假装不认识，
其实这个时间轴是能说得过去的，
我跟他认识的时候，
我24，
他25，
那你现在纠结的点是什么？
想问的问题是，
我就从她口里出来的，
是认识我之前没有认识任何人，
那茬对我来说无所谓，
我能接纳。
我想遇到的一个人是，
就是两个人进往一处死的人，
那你遇到了吗？
没遇到，
那如果说你没遇到，
你怎么知道你跟他分开了之后，
一定能找一个跟你交往一起处死的人呢？
确实是因为未来是不确定的，
你这段关系怎么维持，
要不要维持下去？
其实从你内心来看的话，
你没有真正瞧得起你的妻子，
为什么我说你心里没有真正瞧得起这个女人呢？
因为你刚刚。
哪个词叫宽恕啊，
你说他如果不这么干的话，
我就能宽恕他，
就从这个措辞就能看出来，
就在你的心里的话，
你一直是把他看成是你的手下，
因为他从出现在你生命里的时候，
他就是你的手下，
你相当于是一个管理者嘛，
她在厂子里面打工的时候，
她是替你管的嘛，
所以你没有把她当成一个平等的女性来对话，
来对待，
而且这些年也是主要你养家嘛，
主要你挣钱嘛，
所以呢，
可能他在这段关系当中也是没有得到过一个男人的真正的平等的对待和尊重，
他才会对你有各种的怀疑，
疑神疑鬼，
尤其是当你事业发展了，
你能够从这么差的基础，
能够一步一步靠自己的努力走到今天了，
还能给村子里面做公益了，
那就已经很成功的这样一个角色了，
所以他越来越没有安全感，
那你要是说你在外头也未必能找一个可以齐心协力，
齐头并进的这样一个伴侣的话，
你还有一个选择，
就是退一步看一下我能不能通过调整一下我对他的态度，
我尊重一下他，
我给他一点安全感。
其实我跟你说少来夫妻老来伴，
现在你们家孩子都已经十七八岁了，
马上就已经成年了，
到最后的话就是两个人有一个伴，
去哪儿的话，
有个人知冷知热的担心你吃饱了没有，
穿暖了没有，
就是少来夫妻老来伴，
你还不如说我换个策。
我改变一下我以前那种高高在上的姿态，
我把它当成我手下的一个姿态，
我现在把它当成孩子他妈老伴儿来看待，
我得关心他吃的好不好，
穿的暖不暖，
我得关心他身体健不健康，
你还不如从这个角度下手的话，
性价比高一点，
否则的话，
你看啊，
咱就说40多岁的男的了，
你就说你有一套房吧，
你要是跟他分开了，
这俩孩子小的他还得带着是不是？
就是咱但凡有点良心的话，
不可能把他们娘俩赶出去吧，
那房子他还得住着，
那就得你自己出去找神儿，
自己出去租房子，
你这种情况的话，
咱就是说比上还是真比不上，
你不是那种随便就可以再娶一个女人的经济实力啊，
你这俩孩子还得养啊，
对吧？
一个17岁，
到时候读大学又得花钱，
孩子将来娶媳妇儿也得花钱，
你这头真的顾不上你自己没到那实力，
就是说从性价比来选的话，
回头诶，
好好经营一下这段感情，
性价比更高，
我不知道你一年存到手里，
存到手里你能存多少钱，
咱就刨出去什么营业额，
刨出去什么这人情往来，
又打点这个又回扣那个的，
你手里你能存多少钱，
你在你那个城市，
你要想再买房，
再娶媳妇儿，
再生孩子，
你得花多少成本，
你自己算这个账啊，
听懂了，
但是你如果说往回找该怎么走，
就是往回找的话，
咱现在对于你来说，
前途事业也更重要，
从理性的做法的话，
也是该道歉的，
要赌那个气，
知道吗？
因为对于我们这种人啊，
从底层爬起来的，
这样的人的话。
什最重要，
前途最重要，
什么最重要，
挣钱最重要，
其他都蠢蠢，
所以现在对于你前途摆在这儿，
你低头啊，
就得低头，
就得道歉，
我没有错，
我也要低头，
坦率的说，
你打人就是错，
说破天了，
全世界范围你除非你去印度啊，
你要说你做生意以后在印度的话，
那我就不劝你，
但凡你不是在印度做生意的话，
你全世界你上哪儿，
你夸夸俩大耳巴子，
你打老婆跟那个李阳似的，
疯狂英语的李阳，
那现在那么多人不还天天踩着他吗？
为啥就打老婆？
全世界走哪儿都是错呀，
没有什么可说的呀，
好吧好吧，
好好，
就这样啊，
谢谢，
嗯，
拜拜，
那坦率的说，
我对得起这大哥这几百块钱了，
因为我分析的利弊的话，
对于他来说，
心里面要承认对老婆确实啊，
这些年有点看不起他，
他没有安全感，
他如果承认这一点的话，
他回过头来，
这日子还有过好的可能性啊，
记得点赞关注哦。